the jewish tribe is a very strong tribe
so how do you make sense of this
mention of the stranger versus the power
of the tribe which is the whole point
not the point but right the mechanism of
transition propagates the trial so it's
both i mean the torah does not start
with
jews it starts with adam and eve that's
a way of saying
yeah this is going to be a story about a
people but understand that prior to a
kind of people there are people i like
i'm a human being before i'm a jew
um
and in fact the jewish new year you know
the muslim new year starts with
muhammad's
journey and the christian new year
starts with jesus's birth the jewish new
year starts with the creation of the
world
because the idea is yes this is a
particularist tradition but it makes a
universal statement which is
all of humanity is a child
are in the image of god or children of
god
i think that the idea of judaism was
to try to exemplify a certain way of
making that statement over and over
again and i want to say one other thing
about chosenness um
that's very name droppy but when i tell
you how i got there it won't be as name
droppy
so
my brother is a professor at emory
and so is the dalai lama actually
teaches at emory although he no longer
does because he's too old to go to emory
but for many years taught at emory and
so
my brother brought us he's the head of
the bi of the ethics center at emory
he's a bioethicist so he brought a bunch
of students to dharamsala to meet with
the dalai lama so i went to india i was
on sabbatical then anyway i met my
brother there and and we had a chance to
meet with the dalai lama
okay that was the name drop so we're
sitting in the ark before he speaks to
the students he was speaking to us but
not because i just wanted to make it
clear not because he said oh i got to
talk to that rabbi just we just happened
to be
i happen to glom along with my brother
we sit down the first thing he says is
he points at me and says what's this
about the chosen people anyway
so and he had by the way and he had
asked that i give a lecture which i did
later to to them to his monks about how
jews survived in the diaspora so it's
not like he doesn't know about judy he
knows a lot about it but he says right
away with so i said yes jews believe
that they were chosen for a certain
mission in this world
but that doesn't mean other people
weren't chosen for other sorts of things
they certainly i mean seems to me that
other people believe they're chosen for
things too he burst out laughing and
said yeah we also think we're chosen so
i think the idea is that no tribe is
better than
from a better no from a jewish
perspective
uh you're chosen for a thing right
uh
but that doesn't make you better no the
only place where the bettors came in
honestly if i'm going to historically if
i'm going to be honest was not with the
idea
that you but it was when jews were
small persecuted
the way that you take this sort of
psychic revenge is by saying no we're
better than our persecutors even you
know yeah um but the idea is yeah
different people have different missions
which is
i mean like there was a jewish
philosopher franz rosenschweig who used
to say he didn't know very much about
islam he used to say judaism is the sun
and christianity was the rays of the sun
like judaism introduced the idea of god
and christianity brought it to the world
you